what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg here today I'm about
to show you guys my interview my my
first time ever meeting Tom clementieff
who plays mantis in the Guardians of the
Galaxy franchise I wanted to first start
this video off by saying thank you to
everyone who is the supporter of this
channel because I'm aware I'm just some
doofus on the internet so the fact that
I get to have this sit down with an
actress who I really admire I get to ask
her questions that I genuinely want to
know the answer to is just plain and
simple a privilege that wouldn't be
possible without all of you so a sincere
thank you we got to talk about a lot of
great things I think you guys have
really enjoyed especially if you guys
are a fan of her work the second thing I
wanted to say a thank you for is thank
you to everyone who bought tickets for
the special live event that I am doing
this coming Sunday May 7th with
Christian harloff and John campia at
Flappers comedy in Burbank see a couple
months ago we United to do a live
spoiler talk for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania sold out really fast it was
such a great event got to meet so many
of you guys after the show but
especially talk to many of you during
the show it was seriously a blast one of
the best moments of my YouTube career we
thought we'd do it again for a Marvel
movie that we all three genuinely loved
and let's go Forest Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. we've still got some
in-person tickets available so there's a
link in the description box if you guys
want to come last time it was only in
person but if you can't make it in
person for this one you can now stream
it from anywhere in the world we have
pay-per-view links available as well
both links in the description box thank
you again can't wait to meet all of you
who are going to be attending in person
it's going to be a an absolute blast
enjoy the video guys
and we are growling
uh say the camera yeah this is my first
in-person junkers
actually your laces are like undone are
you okay uh yeah I'll just trip during
this interview
an outlet for us my name is Greg Alba
and I'm with uh real rejects hi pom
pleasure to meet you nice to meet you
too I know you've been hearing all day I
want you to know I mean it more than
everyone else I love the hell out of
this movie I loved it so much I've
rewatched all the Guardians movies and
the holiday special and and then of
course this movie and I feel like one of
the biggest earmarks about the portrayal
of mantis that you have is she she can
go from being very soft-spoken to then
having this like deep monstrous voice
right yes and I know a lot of times
that's played for comedic laughs but
mantis has a lot of like pain in her as
well so I was wondering even though it's
played generally for comedy is any of
that choice consciously imbued in
representing the pain within her oh I
didn't think of that but so it's it's a
it's a good one
I mean I feel like sometimes also for
people who are like shy you know they're
like more soft-spoken and sometimes
there's a burst of you know of something
stronger and it needs to come out you
know in in fermented she gains in uh in
confidence to in self-confidence so yeah
some she needs to to stand up for
herself so it
yeah she said comes out of her you know
but it brings comedy too it's very
satisfying yeah you feel you feel like
you're far it happens yeah
I can imagine as you know one of the
best parts about playing mantis is that
because she's such a highly sensitive
empath that when you have like a a scene
like where you're seeing or scene
partner one of the best parts is you get
to just literally feed off of what
they're giving you and let that kind of
guide the scene let that guy how you
play the scene so I was wondering is
there any actor in particular in this
room I know everyone's amazing in this
franchise but is there any actor in
particular that you find you find it the
easiest to connect with and play off of
them just feeling their emotions
oh my God there's such
incredible actors and beautiful human
beings that they're all really easy to
connect with you know and I care deeply
uh
um for them you know so there's not like
one one person in particular it's I
can't choose
choose now
die
[Laughter]
that's actually the best answer that to
give for that when I was watching the
holiday special and then also watching
this ego is mentioned briefly in this
movie and so much of mantis's Journey
has been you know her coming into her
own and not living a life of servitude
by the way it reminds me of Kurt Russell
I I love Kurt but he like called me his
bug daughter or like buggy daughter oh
really it's so cute very different
Dynamic than what the actual ego
character is like yeah he's so nice in
real life when the movie he's so evil
but I was I was wondering when I was
re-watching Guardians 2 I was thinking
that there was probably so much like
you know character history and memories
that you probably had to create that we
didn't get to learn about but now it's
been such a long journey does any of the
character memory Arsenal that you
created from Guardians 2 all those years
ago did any of that factor in before you
did any scenes in this Guardians movie I
do
I don't really work that way creating
memories and things like that I just um
you know have conversations with James
and then I just said create my own
little world and way of moving and
um you know I connect with you know real
emotions and I just I don't know it's my
little like
dense in my brain I don't know how to
explain it's awesome but like you know
I'm not like method or I'm not like
thinking about the character for hours I
just I don't know I just like listen to
music that inspires me sometimes I'm
inspired by the praying mantis I watched
videos of praying mantises dancing or
fighting
um I just think of myself when I was a
child too like how would I would speak
and how I would react and um yeah and
sometimes it's just like you know saying
the words
um and savoring each word and also being
being not an English speaker at first
you know I'm French it's just like I
think it's it's just creates a different
tone in the voice in the the way I say
things and the different music so I
guess I don't know that's how I created
the alien I guess so it's just like
letting go and going with the instincts
the whole time yeah oh that's a
beautiful answer to have
um one of my favorite Parts in this
whole thing that you have with the
Guardians movies is of course like the
interaction that you can have with with
Drax which I'm pretty good probably
asked about a lot I think if anyone does
a Google search on you they'll see that
you're one of like the toughest people
working in Hollywood today as soft as
you are is it also like you're like a
daredevil of sorts but at the same time
there's so much ribbing and making fun
of that you guys do with each other that
does it ever get to a point where
actually I got two full questions it
ever get to a point where the Improv can
you do you guys ever get offended has it
ever gone too far or are you guys even
harsher to each other when the camera's
not rolling when making oh my God never
Dave is such a sweetheart he would like
never know we have so much fun I want
him like to like say that I'm disgusting
and ugly so hilarious you know and yeah
and sometimes like does he call me an
or something at some point it's
so funny
oh that's amazing it's hard to not like
not like to not laugh during the scene
you know so I have to like be serious
and be like in character you know yeah
of course well uh yeah I love this movie
uh I feel like you've just gotten
progressively more amazing than each
installment oh thank you so much I just
wanted to say at the end of the holiday
special especially on my re-watch I'm
like man that does bring me to tears
Europe oh my God I mean you know it's
James Gunn's talent to be able to um uh
to create such a beautiful balance
between deep emotion and entertainment
and and very very funny scenes as well
you know it's just I don't know it's
it's very special for sure of course of
course well thank you so much for your
time I had a really busy day but thank
you for being so generous thank you
thank you so much
foreign